head coach of the Stanford Cardinal he's
been the coach of the year in the pac-12
four times David Shaw joining us from
his home even though you've got a campus
shot over your shoulder coach I'm
assuming that your home is not close to
campus where that's the actual picture
out your window yeah of course because
no one can actually afford to live
anywhere how often are you using zoom
with your players as for me personally
periodically my staff a lot what I
decide to do is not have a lot of team
meetings this whole thing has been
traumatic to everybody and so I wanted
the position coaches to spend most of
the time with the guys I want to use up
a lot of their time or wanted to be a
very individual very intimate that's
mainly what we're all missing is those
those personal connections so I wanted
to meet it as smaller groups as possible
so those guys still have that sense of
community I asked this question to Kirk
Ferentz at Iowa yesterday I'll ask it to
you and who's going to decide when you
come back to play football is it up to
the governor is it up to the president
is it up to you is it up to the pac-12
commissioner who would make the decision
for Stanford to come back and play
football for me it's a it's a cascading
deal of events to where state and local
governments are gonna have a big say on
which areas can open and when our
president and provost at Stanford are
gonna have their process in place
there's been a lot of meetings about how
to reintegrate people on the campus
whether it's a closed campus and stay
online or partially open and partially
closed and bring some student backs with
social social distancing so a lot of
those things have to happen and then
when it comes to actually playing dr.
Haines line at the n-c-double-a a lot of
the every conference has its own medical
Medical Group Consortium if you will
talking about the process of not just
playing a game but reintegrating a team
back together and
the testing is at the forefront and
isolation and all those things that need
to have happen as we hopefully continue
to push for vaccine so there has to be
processes in place to get people back
together but at the same time processes
to make sure if someone does can
contract the virus they can quickly be
be found and isolated to keep it from
becoming a team-wide situation do you
allow yourself to have contingency plans
hypotheticals and the reason why I say
this the NFL Commissioner said to all
the teams no hypotheticals don't talk
about hypotheticals we're gonna be
playing football in the fall and that's
why the schedule is gonna go off as you
know as scheduled here but it's about
planning yeah I think they're the NFL
and college football in similar
situations but not the exact same
situations they've got a collective
bargaining agreement they got all kinds
of stuff I've got owner team owners etc
we've got college kids so I think for us
we need to talk about all the
possibilities all the eventualities and
not to mention we've we're not on the
same page all the time as far as all the
conferences are concerned let alone the
different levels of Division one two
three so we have to talk a lot about
contingency plans what happens if this
happens what happens if this happens
were there to be transparency with our
own players too first we have
transparency for scheduling what happens
if one campus shuts down the other ones
not shut down and can we still play a
football thing so there are a lot of
things that we have to talk about so
that when the fall does come we are able
to play football and we can deal with
all the things that can come up yeah and
we had talked to the SEC Commissioner
and I said can you see where maybe not
all schools are gonna be playing
football in the fall but the SEC
continues to play let's say 12 schools
want to play football their states allow
them to play football
what if Vanderbilt decides it's not
going to play or northwestern in the big
10 or Baylor in the big you know big 12
like it feels like you might have
conferences are gonna play football
without all their teams can you see that
happening because everyone that I've
talked to and I'm on multiple committees
conference committees n-c-double-a
committees everyone I've talked to has
said that everyone wants to play
football it's just whether or not it's
gonna be possible so that's what a lot
of the commissioners are gonna have to
deal with and I mentioned earlier
scheduling is gonna be is gonna be
fascinating it all depends if if a lot
of states stay closed and we get towards
training camp then we have to adjust the
schedule so as many teams as possible
can play and then we have to play each
other so I do believe everyone has the
intention of playing I really hope and
pray over the next couple of months or
so that we have more available rapid
diagnostic testing which is huge to find
out very shortly if someone does have a
virus we can isolate them and keep it
from becoming spreading amongst an
entire team so I think that's that's
everyone's attention is to play some
form and then the biggest issue which
has come up from Bob Bosley at the big
12 from many people in c-double-a we
have to have those contingency plans to
say let's say something happens during
the season and either one team or
multiple teams or all of college
football is interrupts we have to have a
contingency plan for that as well each
David Shaw Stanford head football coach
joining us Dan Patrick show tell me if
this is true or not the first time you
saw Christian McCaffrey in high school
was not on a football field it was on a
basketball court the first time I
actually saw him was on campus at
Stanford we were recruiting his older
brother Max and ed ed McCaffrey brought
his boys by and met Max and great
conversation with Max and he brought
they brought their younger brother and I
got this steely eyed stare and this very
firm handshake from this point kid as
well those deals were I'll never forget
I looked at him I shook his hand and I
started to look back at it and the
handshake was so firm I looked back at
him and kind of like tilted my head like
oh wow okay you're like this now I just
did that's always stuck out to me I know
if he's gonna be a good player or not
and then as soon as I saw the film from
him I think first film we saw was a
little bit of a sophomore year I said
you've got to be kidding me
like this this is kids a sophomore but
he's making people look silly and then
his junior
film was off the charts and then the
senior film of four so every year the
kid is played football he's been great
and the next year he's been better there
was no thought like he was playing
running back he was coming there he's
playing running back right we we said he
was playing football because defensive
back he was the best defensive back on
the field he was a pump returner I still
say he's probably the best gunner we've
ever had and I watched him do it in one
practice and I said there's nobody in
America that can stop this guy as a
gunner but we can't play him a gunner
he's gonna have the ball in his hands
you look at the running back position
position now David I don't know if it
affects how you recruit you know college
is different than the pros but how we're
utilizing running backs are they're not
as valuable now you know you don't want
to waste a top ten pick it feels like on
running backs but how do what do you
look for in a running back and and how
is it different in college than the pros
so that's a great question and I don't
think it's that different as far as most
of the teams go I agree you can't waste
a top ten pick on a pure running back
but if that guy gives you versatility
effective gives you what Christian
McCaffrey can give you that be able to
catch the ball out of the backfield will
be able to run the ball between the
tackles and outside and be a returned
man a guy that can play in a lot of
snaps and do a lot of different things
for you that guy is now extremely
valuable because now he's one of your
easier best running back he's also one
of your best receivers he's a return man
I think what's a qualm Barkley gives
gives the Giants that that big
playability where it doesn't have to be
it can be anything you toss sweep and
inside run and outside run anything can
score any catch the ball in the
backfield so those the versatility to me
is the biggest change in last how many
years now you're looking for that
versatile guy he's extremely dynamic but
if you've got a group of good running
backs yeah now you just got a good ran
backs you still win with those guys but
you've got a difference maker then
that's worth going to get that guy how
often did recruits think that you were
NC State as opposed to Stanford like
before you guys didn't you put the tree
into the logo just because they thought
you were NC State or Syracuse or is that
true
absolutely I'm not gonna deny it when
when we got here with coach Harbaugh in
2007 I'll never forget it I was I was
the East Coast guy I was I came out of
nine years in the NFL I had never really
been on a recruiting trip so I you know
got the logo on and going to places and
and I walk in and I says hey NC State's
here I mean in Jersey and the case at
Syracuse I know it's so I started
wearing the full Stanford so a big
thankful tonight a thankful to Bob Mosby
at the time to really differentiate our
logo so that we could actually be
recognized but as we all know the
biggest reason why we started
recognizing starting of course of course
well I have two kids who went to USC we
were in South Carolina visiting oh yeah
I know I know they couldn't get into
Stanford David yeah they couldn't get in
there I would have sent them there but
they were in South Carolina with a
hooting the Blowfish concert and they
had their SC stuff on and people said
all you went to South Carolina and the
looks on their face and my kids were
like South Carolina no we went to you
the USC so they faced it as well it's
great to talk to you hopefully we get
some football there and thanks for
joining us we appreciate it
that's David Shaw he's the head coach at
Stanford